all'asta prima di tutto il mondo ok
basta un introdotto si sta per me va
bene come introduzione 7 va bene c'erano
la faccia buona caratura di file hi fi
che gli posso vedere il picco della
qualità del mio canale che così sta
facendo così si sa pro prego ragazzi
prego ciao ragazzi segnalati già andrea
marco marino e giampiero per fare un
render che era una novità non lo facevo
di rendermi formate le fatto sacco però
zanus se non avessi più gioca come la
turchia sono marco liconti margine
allora c'è un gioco che devi prendete ti
metti a d'orsi anni tu devi scegliere
quale delle due pareti uno esclude
l'altro ovviamente è tutto condito dalla
traduzione di google che produce molto
bene va bene come leader preferiresti
ammalarmi per essere temuto e
particolare il fatto che si arrossa 2
parte dell'italia nel giorno esatto
palco direi essere amato perché essere
temuto come leader
vuoi dire sempre che prima o poi ci sarà
un piccolo nucleo di ribelli che verrà
fatto uno così però dicono ti posso dire
anche secondo me firmato solo gli
stronzi
certo che dicono moreno in quello il
caso di necessità la gente chiamerà the
con qualche motivo il fatto qual è più
alto come sentimento l'odio verso i
ribelli o l'odio verso la gente se la
prende con te che ti fa amare il mio
discorso onesto
sono stato molto molto però bene o male
che mi chiedo è molto temuto
non è che anche io ho amato sono dalla
partita e vediamo d'amore quelle cose
che ha fatto lui ma direi quindi che
quindi niente nava meglio io metto amati
perché herat era almeno 18 per cento
beni che fa è bellissimo essere tra
nella minoranza vuol dire che siete i
più particolari di speciale un modo per
il turismo e per i resti
nessun figlio unico e abiti vedere una
famiglia di giro dello show di la
seconda direi senza il nonno da quel
codice senso si sia presa e che te lo
sia primario di pilar e su ma ma che
cazzo dici marco ok
immaginate se trillo del noto tenere a
casa prima che le dava e voi che lo dava
avrebbe funzionato fino a 16 anni perché
io sono diventato così e non era di
fatto viene misura vendicato facendolo
io di certo ma poi anche l'aria 38 certo
abbiamo chiamato di vedere o lillo sono
marco o se ti stiamo registrando un
video con noi ruber più figo l'italia fa
vj e stavamo parlando di te di un mio
ipotetico abusare di te sessualmente
vorrei sapere un tuo ipotetico godere se
stai alle tombe cioè come prestito con
la voce di ciò che sto trattando bene ha
eletto papa un figlio più altro figlio
non poco
ma lei non verso una cosa mi diresti
dolce stai attento perché non c'è
pertanto ne vado vado veloce grande di
acqua viene inserito bene è bellissimo
di un anziano a tutto campo dalla grazia
lillo buona per star provava che non te
li ho fatti gli auguri io chiarimenti in
testa
ciao ciao ciao ciao paghiamo le con
mamma la mia vita è come un altro tono
di queste elezioni è bellissimo è un
mese di sofferenza preferiresti essere
costretto a camminare per un mese intero
senza pantaloni o lasciati tutti i
capelli per un mese intero la città tv
stick abele la sose peraltro per un mese
la seconda senza un breve tour bisogna
assolutamente lar l'ho anche fatto
assente dopo in figlio era lo presti
molto strano un'indagine rose le vesti
per non dire veramente brutto dio fa un
crescente favore fatto vedere come sarei
andato ho penato non so niente vero un
proiettile privacy sarebbe 27 maggio lo
so di lei la pelata se con me va
accompagnata dalla barba se non silenzi
e io non so quale diverso dai miei la
coppetta cosa sei collina
e cappellino in giro la gente esce di
casa per mesi vivere in isolamento
affrontare la tua più grande paura una
volta almeno a me ma sono metafore caffè
raia fa più grande paura vivere una cosa
tipo agoni io morirei aiuto se muore il
governo trovi prendi suonato per strada
solo per sempre ce la posso cambiare la
mia più grande paura nessun comune del
campo per un'ora intera ma lui anni
bovina gli odiati la mia peggiore favore
senioradio con gli aquilani e con le
siringhe
io preferisco vedere all isola
realizzando un fatto è che adesso di
fumo diffuso questa mia grande paura
pubblicamente su internet scherzoso
dipende dallo scherzo ma potrei perdere
la testa
dunque io io sinceramente vivere in
isolamento non è vero non è possibile
che io però si aspetta vivere di
isolamento è inutile allora per net o
mine vivere in isolamento
c'è e come quanto tu sei da solo chiusi
in camera immaginate il mondo senza
persone vuoto completamente
ci sta affrontare la tua poco la tua più
grande bolla di una volta eletto nella
notte rock i tempi un sacco o magari
perdi la brocca arriva domani a gare
pubbliche quelle cose ma smettila con è
praticamente alla domanda seria che
cos'è una vetro ma perché voi non sanno
soffrite anni non potete capire che
avremo domani ne dà un segnale di ron
haviv e revisione a me ma se non lo so
ride di berna guardate come è normale
che mancavano tantissimi bruno di noi un
mini cavallo di cavallo lo intendono ma
è certo cosa certa la be or not to love
iii non fa che ebbe bisogno 6 è sempre
la mezzo per perso ha detto mille volte
ma gli ostacoli con le gomme è ben più
alto del 40 per cento fossero un normale
mica la ragazza mi richiamano pensateci
un attimo
prendete niente è carino fate per la
prima con gli amici lo metti in tasca
nel taschino che cazzo me ne frega mi
prendo una moto come gli uomini come ci
fai giugno si innamorasse non me ne vado
fa il commercio solo comprano tutti è
però floppy primi giochi e bellissimo
metrò che bellissima io la chiamerei e
tina apple sono piccola
gestione per boom visto che gestisco che
tra licei saranno i video del suo primo
anno ma ridoppiato tutti ci metterei la
firma
l'eterno preferiresti avere il 50 per
cento del tuo corpo bruciato al cento
per cento con il 100 per cento vuol dire
che divenuti tossine rinate che hanno
semplicemente accelerasse consegna
ovviamente si fanno un tatuaggio bianco
i generi perché non ci sono mike tyson è
nata può tenersi ma perché lui non è
proprio nero nero abbiamo realizzato
sono i neri bull cento per cento di e
tutto ragazzi e fast in analisi 95 ha
detto io mi brucia le partite ne
uccidono molto dai fate che il corpo
brucia trezzi e irritante
io conosco una ragazza che ce l'ha più
per supplire di poterlo al cielo brucerò
sveglia è male 102 103 come lo ha fatto
la gente di avvelenamento ma secondo me
non hanno capito che il 100 per cento
del 100 per cento rincon nasi che male
che farà pace dentro mannini ski vabbè
vabbè dai resti lecca scenari il
tassista sull'auto immagina cela nelle
orecchie di un bel chiude non ha mai con
i dolori e le conosce la dentista
aspettare tutti ragazzi io come ben
saprete preso un sacco di esperimenti
con me stesso e so bene cosa stiamo
parlando sia un caso che nell'altro
pensa te che magni che uomo vissuto la
risalita si sta sudato è orribile però
il cerume una cosa che è figlia del
cielo e comunque se non ti anima le
orecchie e su roma lo stesso sapore
sempre in una specie di pungere tino e
pungente del gioco a questo gioco coi
miei amici lo leggono tutti in modo
scarso e quindi me la vivo in un certo
modo quando le leggi brafa riga del 318
per cento e questo è quello che non
dovrei
si fa quel che si può pensate a maggio
c'è scritto non sprecare la scelta è la
mia fatto sussiste una lobby rispetto
dove ci per cento se tu fossi in uno
show di broadway preferiresti essere
protagonista il wicket con del re leone
dell'orefice ragazzi chi vorrei fare
vedere leone scala che anch'io non ci
staresti muscardini garanti farina simba
allora no io amo fase o cumbo anch'io
bella più lesmo lo soffre precisa che la
porta a lenzi che hai fatto abbiamo
fatto un mese che ho fatto
infatti fanno ei timori
niente un'occhiata qui sembra che sia
ancora vivo che figata
va bene ragazzi a un prossimo
[Musica]